technicians add the heating element a
cable that is wrapped around the piece
of furniture the cable is tacked in
place with a separate mix of concrete
that has a higher fiber
content the entire heating element is
embedded in a full coat of the high
fiber concrete then a finishing coat of
the first mix is applied and the
structure is left to cure at room
temperature for 24
hours now cured this white chair is
ready to be extracted a tech I pumps
compressed air through the drain hole
insert due to the release agent
application the cast chair easily pops
off the
mold the rough edges are smoothed with a
diamond
file then the drain hole plug is
removed